to tell you more about the new types of
play the joy con will enable and to tell
you about Nintendo switch software I'd
like to switch things over to general
development producer yoshiaki koizumi
thank you very much hello everyone I am
Nintendo switch general development
producer yoshiaki Kazumi it's great to
be here controllers are very important
when it comes to video games right and I
suspect all of you are wondering what
the Nintendo switched joy con are like
allow me to introduce them to you in
detail these are the joy con set in the
joy con grip this is the basic style
when playing on the TV now let me remove
the joy con
these are the joy cotton
there is a left and a right toy con each
joy Khan has an analog stick and each
stick can also be pressed like a button
this joy Khan has the familiar a B X Y
button and beneath them is the home
button it's this house shaped mark there
is an NFC reader writer that can read
and write an EVO data as well and please
look at the square button on this joy
calm this is the capture button for
capturing screenshots of your gameplay
in the future it will be able to capture
video as well you will be able to share
the screens you capture with friends
over social media and each joy Khan
includes accelerometer and gyros
independent left and right motion
control like this possible and take a
look right here there are two buttons in
the rail that connects the joy continent
endo switch console these are L&R
buttons because of this design each joy
con can be used as a fully functioning
individual controller you can hand a joy
con to the person next to you in mini to
play your games we call this sharing the
joy so Nintendo switch comes with two
controllers right from the start and
when you play with these joy con they
fit in the palm of your hand just right
like this and they feel very natural
for example pardon me you can release
the tension from your shoulders and
relax while you play that's all for my
joy kind introduction honestly clone but
some I still have many things to share
about the joy calm
[Music]